the four of 400 is a list of the 400
richest people in america this is the
40th annual list forbes started it in
1982. the richest person back in 1982
when we did the list was worth 2 billion
so this year the 400 members all
together are worth a whopping 4.5
trillion dollars that's up from 3.2
trillion a year ago it's a really huge
number it's hard to even
imagine what a trillion dollars is but
the stock market increases in companies
like amazon and facebook and
google alphabet have just pushed the
particularly the very richest of the
rich up to stratospheric levels
[Music]
so jeff bezos is number one richest at
201 billion dollars is the first time
we've had somebody worth more than 200
billion on the forbes 400. behind him at
number two is elon musk whose net worth
has just rocketed in the past year
because of the growth in the value of
tesla stock and then at number three is
mark zuckerberg
this is the first year since the early
1990s that bill gates has not been in
number one or number two spot so bill
gates is at number four below zuckerberg
bill gates's fortune has shrunk a little
bit because of the divorce with that he
got divorced um
this year and he transferred
a little bit less than six billion
dollars worth of his stock to melinda
french gates his ex-wife so that's
probably knocked him down a little bit
in the rankings it's possible
that bill gates has transferred even
more of his assets to
melinda
they're not talking they have a secret
separation agreement we know about this
transfer of assets because there have
been public filings of stocks that gates
has owned bill gates has owned a bunch
of um but it could be he could be
transferring other assets where there's
no public records available
and they're not talking so hopefully
we'll find out more about that in the
future
but melinda is new to the list
um because of the divorce
she's worth about six billion dollars
the google founders larry page and
sergey brin um follow right behind bill
gates and then larry allison
and then warren buffett
new in the top 20 for the first time um
are stephen schwartzman the founder of
um co-founder of blackstone whose shares
of like more than nearly doubled in the
past year and then also lynn blavatnik
who is a soviet-born entrepreneur who's
a big investor in warner music and also
um chemicals company lion del blasel and
many other assets
this year we saw a lot of new people on
the list we've had 44 newcomers
which is pretty amazing because to get
onto the forbes 400 list
it took a fortune of 2.9 billion dollars
which is the highest
cutoff we've ever had and it's 800
million dollars more than a year ago so
for the past
few years it's taken 2.1 billion to get
on the list and so when you get to
number 400 that person is at 2.9 billion
so it's it's kind of crazy so that means
a lot of people who dropped off
didn't necessarily get poorer
there's but they just got passed by by
folks who
are whose stocks are going crazy some of
the newcomers are
in growing fields um like cryptocurrency
and one of the most prominent newcomers
is a 29 year old sam bankman freed sam
bakeman freed is based in hong kong and
has started
cryptocurrency exchange and also a
crypto um company and he's
signing up high profile athletes tom
brady and steph curry and the like to be
spokespeople for his company for ftx he
wants to get as rich as possible so that
he can give it all away
but he hasn't started giving away very
much yet so we'll see where it goes but
we have a super interesting story about
him um on the cover of the magazine we
have um electric vehicle billionaire r.j
scarange his company is rivien which has
gotten a large order of vehicles from
amazon he's worth 3.4 billion dollars
that's the company's still private
although it is filed to go public um and
so it will go public in in the future
the most prominent drop-offs for this
year's 400 are donald trump
and oprah winfrey
basically
neither of them got a whole lot poorer
in fact they're either flatter or higher
than they were a year ago
but it's just that everyone else got so
much richer and kind of passed them by
a couple other um interesting drop-offs
um jim koch behind sam adams beer um
boston brewery they had made a big bet
on their seltzer i should say hard
seltzer
that's called truly with sales of which
kind of plummeted this year and the
stocks down about 50
so the interesting thing about um this
year's
of the force 400 most people's net worth
is up there only a few people's net
worth dropped and then even of the
drop-offs
many people are flat but not that many
people who fell i mean the main thing is
just the the shocking increase in
how rich the richest americans have
gotten and the fact that so many are are
worth more than a year ago and we also
looked at um philanthropy so we have for
each member of the list we have a
philanthropy score and the score is
based on how much of their net worth
they have given away and that's not how
much they've given to their own private
foundations but how much like if they
have you know the bill and melinda gates
foundation or somebody has a foundation
in their own name how much is that
foundation given so we're looking at out
the door giving how much has gotten from
to into the hands of you know non-profit
organizations who are using the money as
opposed to sitting in a foundation
you know of course as your net worth
increases
people's people's giving is not
increasing at the rate that their net
worth is increasing it's sort of what
that says
um we don't have scores for all of the
people on the list there's some people
for whom we don't know anything about
their philanthropic giving and they
don't want to tell us
and so it could be that they're not
doing any or that they're doing it
anonymously
we don't know but it's possible to to be
an anonymous donor we just we don't know
at a time where we're still like the
global pandemic is not over
you know the delta variant certainly
made things worse across the country in
a lot of states and so it's a little bit
of a disconnect for us to see you know
news about people dying of cove and
people being hospitalized with covid
hospitals being overwhelmed with covered
patients and and yet the you look at the
stock market and that's sort of not
reflected in that at all um that these
people are getting richer than ever and
some of them are you know hiding out on
on their yachts in
off of the coast of fiji and you know
being able to separate themselves from
the masses because they can afford to do
so stocks up everybody's net worth is up
so the question is will the stock market
stay where it is and if it does or if it
keeps rising we'll see more billionaires
we certainly have seen a lot of of ipos
of of companies that have
minted new billionaires even just in the
past month um so we could see more of
that going forward but i think it's
really the key for the future of
billionaires wealth and the number of
billionaires is tied to the performance
of the stock market
you